I'm gonna play a couple of things that
have been happening including Sal's
weird pronunciations you know the word
Villa I have a villa in France perhaps
you'd say he calls it a villa I hate to
say this
yeah wrong but both in Italian get out
of here you're in America [ __ ] first
of all I'll tell you what you're not
from Italy you didn't grow up in Italy
you've never been in Italy I've been to
yeah okay here's south from the wrap-up
show yesterday listen to this guy
women love men who are successful so you
have to play the success card you have
to you have to paint the big picture 90%
of the time a woman is not going to be
attracted to the average guy right off
the bat but if you give her a reason
like you have a mansion like you have a
place in the Hamptons like you have a
villa in Italy stuff that most likely
she won't see
Vila Garside what do you have in Italy I
thought he was saying like you're really
exaggerating I'm gonna get you because
you seem like a bright guy honestly I
think I'm a bright guy but in Italy they
say Vilas they say Venice table you look
I forget Sal being an idiot with the
word Vila okay listen to this this is
from the wrap-up show you don't get
caught up in what the content is do you
remember what that whole Jim Jones thing
was about yeah he had an occult he gave
all these people cool lame they drop
dead wait he had what he had this a cult
I think it's called an occult right they
say a cult how'd you learn how to say
that wrong well a cult
I heard Daniel was cult not a cult but
an occult is I think it's a comedy
it's like satanic groups there are cults
but I thought it's the same thing I long
as it's a group sound do you ever read
you ever ever like take an interest in
the dictionary so busily saying a cult
they're not saying a cult they're saying
a and then a word see you LT cult hey
cult and then there is the occult the
occult or a cult is holy cow what I see
occult
OC OCC your ult whatever it is and you
hear people say in a cult I'm not always
thinking it's a cult now I never I never
distinguish the difference between a
cult and a cult when you win you only
Chow where did you grow up man and don't
give me this [ __ ] home because you
were in Italy yeah
because when I come to my villa you know
it says that like from Transylvania I
want you to come to my view
you